so this is the EMF network operation
center this is where we've been building
and staging and then deploying the
network from all week this is where the
switches get configured everything
tested sent out with the Wi-Fi access
points DECT base stations at the Geo 17
come along later and add their GSM base
stations as well this all then goes out
to the dart enclose the decays we call
them on-site so let's start where people
can where they get the internet so we
have blanket wired and wireless coverage
most people prefer Wireless because they
don't have to run a cable but it is
there there's dark and closed within 40
meters of pretty much every tent unless
you've camped in a very strange area
these darting clothes it's it's German
for data toilet and we use them because
they're basically portable toilets
portable loos and inside each is a
switch deck base station we used to keep
the access points inside but now we have
them mounted on poles we find them super
convenient because they're basically a
waterproof box and there is the
potential for things to get wet on the
campsite so if we take a wonder up here
maybe and take a look inside this one so
we put padlocks on the outside just in
case but once you get inside it's pretty
hard to confuse them for a working
toilet we are an access switch for those
who wish to connect by wired ethernet
then also connects to our access point
deck base station gsm-based station on
the roof we also have a light so it's a
sequence of individually addressable
LEDs that change color depending on our
net broadcast messages so apart from
looking cool they're actually a really
useful way to see if the network at a
glance in that dart and Chloe is running
or not so one can look across the field
and see are the power may be out there
the switch may have a problem and head
over and sorted out
so from here is a complex distribution
network of fiber complex physically not
so complex logically each switch in each
of these darkened flow is directly
connected to our core switch but that's
a lot of fiber to run so what we
actually do is we run a fiber from each
one to a kind of hub dart and coat and
we use LC couplers just to patch the
five everyone to another fiber with more
cause and I've picked the wrong one oh
no I haven't so this looks like an
underground splice closure because it
actually is an underground splice
closure this runs underground three
ducts all the way back to our NOC DC our
data center on sides these pop out at a
couple of locations on site and we just
patch on with couplers to provide a
connection to the switch or to the to a
switch and a nearby DK if we walk down
here I can show you where they all
connect logically back to the log DC so
we had two plans for this event one was
our normal plan which is to run fiber
along the ground and along the festoon
lighting which runs through the site
that was our plan B our plan a which we
really wanted to do because we like to
do something a bit challenging in a bit
different every year was to run fiber
through the ducts on the site and I'm
very glad we pulled that off because
it's so much neater and so much easier
to get where you need to go a challenge
on any field is too cool and protect the
servers and the switches that we used to
build the network with or not DC unlock
data center this is this is the solution
we've come up with in 2012 it was a
large scouting tent
with literally and 19-inch rack down one
end but it kept getting covered with
bits of field grass and the like
2014 we had a reefer refrigerated
shipping container which was massive and
really cold the problem was it was too
cold you couldn't set the setpoint high
enough and it condensed so much liquid
it was water blowing all over the
service tarps covering everything not
really good so 2016 we decided we just
rent the same kind of refrigeration unit
that the buy use to keep the beer cold
which
worked out really well the the built-in
chiller that comes with it wasn't quite
enough because it's designed to keep
food cold rather than removed
two-and-a-half kilowatts worth of heat
so we do actually run our own air
conditioning inside so if I can talk to
you through what we have in here we have
our core switch which is this Arista
here
these fibers coming in here are coupled
literally on to the UM underground fiber
that we've run through the site so
that's our core switched core router
this is access for the devices in the
datacenter and on the roof of the
datacenter these are wireless LAN
controllers redundant pair of those UPS
is very heavy UPS is automatic transfer
switch and some servers that run as a
virtual machine cluster that provide all
the services that we provide on-site so
EMS DHCP network monitoring the
configuration management tickets Inc
that kind of thing so the container and
the air conditioner but pretty much
everything else here is on loan from
either a vendor or an organization
called event infer which some of our
teams set up in the Netherlands to kind
of hold donated equipment from vendors
and store it in surest ship it out to
each of these events so it's really
convenient to know long in advance that
we don't have to start flagging through
equipment for the vendors so there's
pretty much no flat surface on their
sites including right here which is why
for the signs saying non-slip mat
between every device and it's why we
have this little pod here to make sure
that the air conditioner doesn't topple
over and crush all the servers and
fibers and switches we have two UPS is
redundant pair and we have an automatic
transfer switch for any servers that can
only take one power supply but as far as
I'm aware
we haven't actually lost power at all in
this area these are our underground
fibers one goes off down the site and
into those underground enclosures that
are currently and ardently the other one
goes well over a kilometer through other
ducts all the way to a green cabinet
that we've installed right by the street
and that's where our circuit actually
terminates we tried to make it as easy
and this pain-free as possible for them
to bring the circuit in and it worked
out really well in the end this will
stay here and if we return in 2020 we
hope to use it again we hope it will be
in good condition we've we've done all
we can to protect it I'm taking you a
very long way all the way back to the
main entrance of the entire Deer Park
right by the main roads
we have a Terrell's prepay I came on the
Thursday to install the camera up from
the hill to do a time-lapse video of the
build and then we started receiving
deliveries Friday morning just before
7:00 a.m. it's unrecognizable we're
using single-mode fiber which can go 10
kilometers and this is about 1.2 it's a
bit shorter as the crow flies but we
have ducting that we have to follow
through this may look like a dart inclu
they may look like a portable toilet but
is also neither this is actually part of
our emergency response plan the mobile
signal and sight is so bad if the
internet connection goes down and we
can't get a call out to 999 someone
could be sent down to this gate that has
a hard-line phone inside I'm very proud
of this this area all the way up to the
toilet up there or the not toilet up
there we dug this up in the freezing
cold in January installed ducts
installed power underground we installed
other ducts out to the road literally to
the property line
here leaving ducts and ropes for the
provider to come and pull their fiber
through later we install the concrete
plinth and then the following weekend we
install this a proper street cabinet so
what we have in here is some power that
is permanently on so not fed from our
generators kindly provided by East nor
Castle we have fiber coming in from our
provider which is then patched into
their network terminating device so this
is what they use to monitor and manage
the circuit in case there's a problem
this is the little device we were using
for testing this is how we were able to
see a month ago that the circuit was
done and that we could get a full
gigabit it was so reassuring to know
that this was going to be ready when we
finally got on site but what actually
happens now is this fiber the accessport
fiber goes into this cupola and directly
onto the same fiber we just saw up at
the not DC and we also have a UPS down
here just in case something happens with
the power supply it gives us a bit of
warning because we actually have that
still connected via a different fiber so
we know that if
that goes down but this still has power
then we've lost power and it's just
running on the UPS so we've got about
ten minutes to get down here with a
generator to make sure the uplink stays
2012 we ran wireless point-to-point 2013
AM wave we ran wireless point-to-point
shorter distance in Docklands but still
point-to-point 2014 another Wireless
point-to-point 2016 we were so lucky to
find the internet provider of the the
nearby business park and make friends
with them and they were so helpful but
this is ours we built this this will
stay here and hopefully we'll be back in
2020 to use it again I think from a
network standpoint there are a lot more
ducks on site and a lot more men how's
that we've only discovered while we've
been doing this build up so there's a
lot more options to put more fiber in to
make it easier to set up next time and
in the future so it'd be great to get
some in there
[Music]
mr. Tom if anyone can figure that out
once you get inside it's pretty hard to
confuse them for a working toilet
[Music]